And men are pretty good at taking care
of children,
you know,
they're,
I would say they're not as good at
taking care of infants as women are
because they don't have the full range
of resources at hand and they're not.
I don't think they're they.
I don't think they have the same kind of
immediate intuitive understanding of or
attraction to babies that men have.
I think that switches around the age of
two or two and a half when the kids can
engage in rough and tumble play because
men are much more likely to engage in
rough and tumble play with children than
women are and rough and tumble play
seems to be one of the things that
symbolizes children.
And it's partly because you know,
one of the things that you have to learn
when you're a child is what actually
hurts you and what can be ignored and
what actually hurts someone else and
what can be ignored.
And the best way to learn that is in
rough and tumble play.
Because what happens is that if you
playing with a kid,
they get more and more excited than they
do.
More and more crazy things until they do
something that either hurts them or,
or hurts you and then you have to say,
look,
you know,
that's,
you can't do that.
And,
and it's,
it's like a dance in a sense,
you know,
when you're wrestling with a little kid
and you have to let them win fairly
frequently because otherwise they don't.
They don't continue the game and you can
tell that because if they're,
if the game is going well,
they're laughing with insane delight
because kids just love rough and tumble
play,
you know,
and,
and they love crazy things.
I mean you can throw them in the air and
catch them and they think that's just
great,
you know,
and,
but partly what you're doing is you're
extending their body in all sorts of
ways and getting them to learn in an
embodied sense where the limits of that,
where their limits are and where the
limits of other people are.
And that's embodied.
And children who haven't had that man,
they're just so awkward.
It's unbelievable.
You know,
they might have some hypothetical sense
of how to interact with another person,
but they don't have an embodied sense of
it and they can't tell the difference
between what hurts them and what
doesn't,
you know,
because often at a young child,
if,
if they're startled,
they'll start to cry and then you can
say,
well,
you know,
that didn't hurt.
And then they'll notice,
oh yeah,
that didn't hurt and they'll stop
crying.
But if they haven't had their limits
tested,
they'll cry at anything unexpected even
if it doesn't hurt.
And that's not good because if you cry
under all conditions,
the probability that you'll make friends
when you're three is like zero because
another kid will start playing with you
and maybe play rough.
And if you burst into terrorists,
you know,
several times the person,
the kids just going to go somewhere else
and find a different playmate.
You know,
they'll say you're just a baby.